I see you have a black panther shirt on
I'm curious um
what are your thoughts on Kanye's
t-shirt that said White lives matter
today that he that he went viral for
wearing his uh fashion show
did you see it of course I've seen this
[ __ ] I mean um White lives matter
t-shirt yeah
look we're like I just I'ma just like
black lives matter bro obviously I'ma
just say that bro that's what I'm gonna
say black lives I'm out of gang I'm just
interested in like whatever his
explanation is because I saw a picture
it's gonna be some well the picture it's
gonna be some like you know what I'm
saying living Buddha live in Christ
Vibes picture of the front of the shirt
was like a bunch of clan members
so I was just very confused I don't know
I do not know what the hell I don't know
bro the only clan that matter is woo
time
by the way Wu-Tang Clan and Nas are
performing in La is that tonight
straight up yeah that's tonight that's
Hollywood Bowl
should we go and bust the Rhymes we
should go Busta Rhymes is opening
that's actually hard the only thing that
sucks about the Wu-Tang aspect
is Method Man's not going to be there
but why you don't he's shooting Power
Wheel right now he just sat he sat it
out you know the Wu-Tang businesses I
mean listen when there's nine guys yeah
somebody ain't gonna be happy I just
seen uh m-e-t-h-o-d man uh
um that's suspense boy he went crazy
that man ain't missing beat dexterity is
impressive I saw Method Man and red man
when I was 12 on the Hard Knock Life
tour yeah I I ain't never seen red man
floating through the air on [ __ ]
wires and [ __ ] and then DMX came on and
then it was Jay that's how you know
they've been smoking weed yeah yeah
they were smoking weed when it was like
the weed that we think is like boof now
is like they're like where are you from
I'm from Phoenix
I will well you grew up on the west
coast yeah was it always Kush with y'all
or was y'all Smoking Reggie Reggie for
sure cause I'm just like the way I'm
like the gas out here just crazy so I'm
like I'm imagining us growing up just
getting our hands on this [ __ ] smoking
like you know what I'm saying like
[ __ ] had to go through the Reggie days
to get to that kush days they had to see
what I'm saying like but I'm like damn
if these little [ __ ] just grow up just
straight up on crack like straight up
cursed out no those Reggie days were I
think about some how some of the weed
used to look back in the day
it used to look that weed used to look
crazy I seen some real Reggie in North
Carolina the other day I bet you did
that's a real ass Reggie bro I wish I
took a picture of that [ __ ] St Louis is
also another one of those like middle of
the country Mark markets that you know
um got the gas right they either have
the gas or they have the some fruit
[ __ ] for St Louis he got that fruit go
the other way or may or may not know
from experience but let's just say
certain guys from certain cities might
come to LA and be like I just need
something that'll pass us indoor in my
city because
because I they don't know better out
there I'll be smoking gas when I'm home
some high-end um you know lots of
high-end light depth [ __ ] Midwest bro
ain't nothing to me about the Midwest
bro I just like that some [ __ ] be
having Reggie and you know what I'm
saying it happens but when I was in
Detroit
um
we were out there maybe two months ago I
went to the liquor store and in the back
of the liquor store uh there was a guy
who was selling
a fake eighth bags from like all the big
like Cali weed companies so they'd be
like an eight like you could buy an
eighth bag of like
runts or cookies or Gary Payton or
whatever and put whatever weeds you
wanted in it and the guy there was like
a line it was like a dollar a bag so you
could just buy whatever weed you get
stuff that I got that new cookie [ __ ]
and it could be anything in there but
it's sealed so do you how much you
selling for a dollar a bag for an empty
bag an empty branded bag
not a bad Hustle
yeah it was ready though no no they were
selling empty bags to people who sold
drugs
oh I missed the whole thing so imagine
you were saying bro just was selling
them imagine this is a bag that says
cookies on it and it's baby blue you
could buy
I think they did a deal if you buy like
a pounds worth of bags so you could just
stuff whatever weed you buy and then
stuff it in there and then you know
that's all yeah finessing the gun super
finesse that's smart super finesse